Ask your rheumatologist
about HUMIRA.
>> WILL YOU COMMIT TO THE CDC
RIGHT NOW USING THAT EXISTING
AUTHORITY TO PAY FOR DIAGNOSTIC
AT THE TIMING FREE TO EVERY
AMERICAN REGARDLESS OF
INSURANCE?
>> WELL, I CAN SAY WE’LL DO
EVERYTHING --
>> THAT’S NOT GOOD ENOUGH.
>> SHANNON: TENSE EXCHANGES
BETWEEN PORTER AND THE CDC ON
CAPITOL HILL.
WE ASKED DR. MARK SIEGEL TO
INVESTIGATE WHAT AMERICANS WILL
HAVE TO PAY FOR THE TEST.
GOOD EVENING, DOCTOR.
>> GOOD EVENING, SHANNON.
AS CORONAVIRUS, COVID-19,
SPREADS THROUGH OUR COMMUNITIES,
THE CONTINUED UNAVAILABILITY OF
TESTING TROUBLES MANY AMERICANS.
DOCTORS AND NURSES NEED THESE
RESULTS TO REASSURE PEOPLE WHO
DON’T CORONAVIRUSHAVE -- V CORON
WHILE ENCOURAGING THOSE WHO DO.
THEY WANT TO MAKE TESTS
AVAILABLE FOR ALL AMERICANS.
SHE CLAIMED THAT THE TEST FOR AN
UNINSURED PATIENT COULD ADD UP
TO AS MUCH AS A WHOPPING $1,331.
>> DO YOU WANT TO KNOW WHO HAS
THE CORONAVIRUS AND WHO DOESN’T?
>> YES.
>> NOT JUST RICH PEOPLE, BUT
EVERYBODY WHO MIGHT HAVE THE
VIRUS.
>> OF COURSE, IRONY THAT OBAMA
CARE WOULDN’T AUTOMATICALLY
COVER THIS TEST IS OBSCURED BY
THE BILLIONS ALLOCATED BY
CONGRESS TO MAKE SURE THESE
TESTS ARE COVERED WITHOUT A
CO-PAY.
THAT IS, IF YOU CAN ACTUALLY GET
ONE.
MEANWHILE, DESPITE EFFORTS BY
QUEST DIAGNOSTIC, LAB CORE AND
TESTING FACILITIES AROUND THE
COUNTRY, THEY STILL REMAIN
UNAVAILABLE.
THEY ARE RELYING ON OUTSIDE
DOCTORS AND HOSPITALS TO PROVIDE
THE SPECIMEN.
CVS IS ENTERING THE FRAY AND THE
FDA HAS JUST APPROVED A MORE
ACTIVE TEST WITH MORE TO FOLLOW
AS THE GOVERNMENT TRIES TO
REASSURE THE ANXIOUS AMERICAN
PUBLIC.
BACK IN 2009 DURING THE SWINE
FLU PANDEMIC, WE ALREADY HAD A
TEST FOR THE FLU.
MOST OFTEN THAT DISEASE COULD BE
RECOGNIZED AND TREATED
CLINICALLY BY DOCTORS AND NURSES
BUT FOR THIS NOVEL CORONAVIRUS
THE TREATMENT AND VACCINE ARE